technically it should be started
so where do you see yourself in five
years
right here doing the Hans Kim podcast
dude I'm the Brennan job of the Hans
Camp podcast I've been on the most
episodes wow and I'm
a great comedian hell yeah yeah
five years from now
uh theaters
like going to the movie theaters that's
cool yeah yeah again finally going
gaining the courage to go to movies you
have real concession stand worker Vibes
I do I do I empathize with them but also
they hire a lot of bad ones Frontline
workers that's right yep Hans five years
five years I expect myself to be
touring comedy clubs and
inside women and
um
I expect myself to be a part of the
Austin comedy scene where we're just
gonna be like a cabal of people just
cabaling it up just destroying the world
together
uh
uh do you want to be like in a mafia
I would like to run your social media
for you if you would allow me why do you
think I'm not good at it no no I just I
don't have any skills or like real
marketable but I help my girlfriend with
her coding College homework like the
last week or two and like I I did a
little coding High School into
Vocational High School for programming
and I'm just like dude I can't believe I
wasted I had so many people telling me
like you're really smart you got to like
work harder and I'm like nah and then
you're 30 you're like [__] that doesn't
mean anything it doesn't mean anything
to be like smart when you're 17. if you
don't do anything
and you just didn't for 13 years yeah
now it's time for that I'm way too far
gone
it's actually relieving in stand up
because it's like it literally is the
only thing I have any marketable it's
not a lot of marketable ability but it's
something yeah so it's like I guess I'm
doing this it's my calling by default
sounds like a good plan yeah
so when this cabal starts
what are what are we gonna do
is there prayer involved
are you gonna head up like a ball you're
gonna be the head of it no there's no
head there's just
everyone's equal
oh
we're gonna starve to death
I think that's preferable
God I could use some being starved
oh wow
look at that you know Jimmy Kimmel goes
24 hours he has 24 hour fast once a week
really yeah that sounds so unpleasant
it really does that does seem pretty bad
I once had like a stomach flu and I
couldn't eat
for like a day like I just it would it
wouldn't have been useful and it's just
sad not being able to eat that's such a
joy that we take for granted I mean not
you but yeah yeah
see I've uh experienced a joy so much
that
but something else I must have come from
like hundreds of years of starvation
our child would be the greatest Eater of
the world I've ever known to the makeup
or
yeah like before this if like uh what is
the one of The Reincarnation was real I
was just like on on some street with
like a you know a [__] bird
there's an eye in me yeah that's a
little cane and you're like
one day it would be the biggest man ever
you don't realize how fat I'll be one
you're gonna be astonished
oh
hey do you what do you think uh if we
reincarnate uh what animals would all of
us be
I would be like a meerkat or like an owl
just quietly judging people
oh I could see owl yeah yeah Goofy
goofy animal that isn't adapted to its
environment very well also wise yeah
just wise to the point of just sitting
there and just being like I could go eat
but that is what animals do yeah it's
like what's the point yeah
deep sea squid are you familiar with the
squid no it's the tentacles are miles
long so like the bottom of the ocean
they're really like nine pictures of it
online
one of the things I'm into is because
like new pictures will surface and it's
like it adds on to a list of only like
20 other like videos I've ever taken on
this thing so like I have alerts set so
I can see it
is how big is the squid I mean I would
say like the body of it probably would
like fit inside this room but then its
tentacles or these ropes that just go
for like miles
wow yeah so why would you do that one
that's just the coolest one not the
coolest
cool hell yeah
so um
do you think this is like a cool podcast
idea where we do a podcast and also sit
in a sauna
it's not too bad this is the only time
I'll be sitting around a desk like this
ever for the rest of my life unless I'm
like being indicted on some type of job
so this is nice it's like a a mediator
you do seem like my lawyer right now
we're not gonna press charges we just
gotta go through this mediation process
arbitration
Paul I think I could see Paul murdering
someone really
I don't think I could you just have a
good face for it yeah I think I would be
good at crimes like Petty crimes if I
did them but I'm a little too anxious
like I'm like a good person simply out
of like anxiety for the most part I
don't have like a moral compass I just
like don't want to have trouble yeah
don't want to be like perceived as bad
to anyone else well that's the thing is
like you see a headache where a killer
sees opportunity so you might see
stand up as a place where it's like oh
have fun and it's something I do and I
can well I'm a killer instead of like a
murderously stand-up comedy and he's
like oh that's a headache that's so much
Social pressure in there I don't even
get to come in front of it yeah much
easier to kill this woman I've been
stalking yeah that's more I sort of gave
up my right to ever own like a firearm
so since two years been in Austin I've
probably threatened to shoot up maybe 14
venues at one point or another like open
mics and stuff because I just have a
habit of saying at the end of my set and
uh so I just decided like I can't own a
gun because if they come to my apartment
I'm gonna have to let them search it I'm
like I know it's a comedy show but I've
made pretty credible threats
at those comedy shows yeah but you can
still own a gun just
it's like another piece of evidence in
this imaginary case that you're building
it that's true but it's fun to threaten
to shoot people so I don't want to own
again yeah
do you want to go Hans go where oh yeah
a gun yeah yeah like a Glock or
something yeah nice like a little
handgun just in case just in case the
heat gets hot yeah it's good to be like
oh if things go down I can handle it
like if if I'm like just stressing out
about something or someone but like oh
if it comes to it I can always use a gun
I can always [__] kill them yeah but
if you don't have a gun then you're like
uh well I have to go talk to him I guess
I gotta figure this out I want one of
those poison dart things I can just
across it
yeah yeah and then you fall yeah that
way it's untraceable
that's what I like the untraceable kills
but I guess that's why Paul likes not
having a gun because he can just think
about it and just I get to talk my way
out of everything just about everything
I get to use my speech
to get out of everything actually I
usually just get like screamed at by
homeless people and then I run away I
don't like like negotiate it all uh
they've been spotting me lately I've
been accosted by like four or five in
the past it's getting hotter you know it
is really yeah I always get but my hair
is this long I get a lot of unwanted
attention from homeless people why do
they think you're homeless I I get a lot
of like
what's up white boy I have a [__] like
that it's happened like three or four
times and my hair is short doesn't
happen wow but it's just like it's you
know they I'm it's like I'm a beautiful
woman you know I'm just beautiful in
there upset but they're not right
they're jealous of the locks yeah I
think you look like you're an
intellectual and you can be accessed
through
like the words so they're like oh let's
[__] with this guy oh yeah because he's
he represents what is cutting us off
from freedom and yeah and I think they
get the idea that I have like a lot more
money than them which is not the case at
all you do have rich person hair really
yeah you should see yourself the way
homeless people see you yeah that's true
I mean I'm not you know
I'm blessed to a homeless person you're
a seven yeah that's good I like that
so uh yeah if things go down I'll make
sure to statistically raise the
likelihood of getting myself shot by
pulling out a gun
that's what some guy said
maybe sword then you know you should
have on the podcast is the uh the Asian
police officer who's in the background
of the George Floyd video what about him
I'll just get his take on the whole
thing because he didn't seem to be happy
about the situation but he was certainly
involved
say that
like another day at the office
should have been a doctor
what I was looking at my phone
it's red who do you think uh
who do you think is lasted in the
longest in bed or no on Earth
no on uh if something terrible happens
where we all have to fend for ourselves
I'm incredibly cunning out of who like
everyone in the world no out of our
story us three yeah lasting the longest
I mean Hans has the most resources and
like uh we have a van weirdo fans that
would probably like the human nature how
do you think fans will translate in the
apocalypse world
like how much can you get from people
that are starving to death
like social they're like oh that's this
isn't a bad guy yeah so they might let
me into their tribe a little depends the
type of fan though because I I
definitely see Allegiance ganks fan
could be like on their deathbed if they
saw Lucy Gomez they'd be like hey yeah
come on in well that's what they don't
show in like zombie movies it's like
d-list celebrities and what it's like to
be a d-list celebrity in the apocalypse
just getting sort of recognized by
people yeah like aren't you that guy
that did that commercial it's like still
a remnant of the old world yeah maybe
nostalgic of like a better time yeah you
know like this is a shaman he's gonna do
a play for us about the before times our
circle is big enough too that like if
you survive for a year or two you'd
eventually definitely would run into
other comedians we know like a thousand
people hey you don't have any mics going
on dude literally they would be doing
[__] they'd be doing open like 100
zombie apocalypse like they look like a
Fallout ghoul like one of their eyeballs
falling out and they would just be doing
like
yeah 100 yeah that's pathetic yeah well
I mean not every comment but I'm
definitely not pathetic like square or
I'm like so I had to kill Anita guy the
other day
foreign
don't you hate it when you have to
kill an innocent person for their
resources like hey I'm not a bad guy I
promise bang oh
zombies walk like this
but non-zombies walk like we're not so
different God
[__] post-apocalyptic comedy is
terrible yeah I mean pretty much all
comedy except for the height of Def Jam
comedy is terrible you know me
your house is
it's good I know there's a vent right
there it doesn't work
it's frustrating what are all these fun
it's kind of worse but then the audio is
silly you guys been here for a while
three hours so far oh yeah yeah I did
we're on hour four
no like probably 10-15 minutes yeah
yeah cool how's it going yeah pretty
good menu pretty good
nice
what'd you get up to Francisco
yeah
Francisco's a horny young he's like Pepe
the Pew Pepe lpu
are you uh recording already yeah
sorry you can't say the N word anymore
okay
so what are you guys talking about what
what did I miss we're talking about uh
if the open mic scene of like comedy
there's a apocalypse
what comedy would be like
post apocalypse and who of us would uh
survive the longest hmm
how do you think you'd fare in the uh
apocalyptic games oh yeah I think it
would I would die probably very very
fast really you think so yeah
um
but uh who came up with that question
Dylan
yeah we're talking about post-apocalypse
apocalypse stuff after I've been
watching a lot of Walking Dead stuff
today
wow
today yeah that's one of those shows I
just watched reels of like Breaking Bad
and I feel like I get the whole sense of
the show but I don't understand really
Let The Narrative of the problem I
haven't seen [__] breaking bad you
can't get Breaking Bad through real I
didn't like it after a few episodes
there are a few reels
[Laughter]
after 30 seconds I was done
I'm not like good television is not
appealing to me it doesn't like I like
to watch Aqua Teen Hunger Force like
over and over again autistically and
then restart the show when I get to the
last season really yeah it's just I
don't know it's like I need comfort in
it like a like a storyline it gives me
too much anxiety I don't need to have
you been watching that for a while now
then yeah that's a great show I love
that show
I'm trying to get my girlfriend to King
of the Hill right now but she's not
vibing with it too what king of the hill
Oh I don't know what that is she doesn't
get it
so uh
what do you think about Stephen Crowder
getting divorced from his wife
did he yeah
did he say why
no
uh didn't he used didn't he start off as
a stand-up yeah that's so funny do you
think his wife was like I'm gonna
divorce you change my mind
well I saw a meme that said my wife is
leaving me change her mind
I think he's gonna be really happy
that's money and he's gonna [__] a bunch
of other women and yeah he's probably
gonna have a blast yeah what do you
think Oz I think he's uh
a sad person that believes in a lot of
incorrect things and it's probably not
pleasant to be with but a lot of like
left-leaning people get divorced too so
I think it's just hard to be with
someone for a long time and we really
shouldn't try to do that unless you have
kids
or at least uh cut the monogamous thing
yeah you can be with someone if you're
not with them for your whole marriage
yeah I can be with anyone for if I can
[__] someone not someone yeah that's
what I mean so relaxed after I come come
home to some unpleasant disgusting
person be like well this is the butt
life
she means well
no yeah I think I think with the Crowder
thing I always
think that would be just such a [__]
hell to be in like to
he you know want to be a stand-up and
then that's not working out so you're
like I guess I'm a politician you're an
inspiring enough to get really serious
I'm gonna have to get super not fun
let me do the opposite of common I feel
like it'd be a hell in general to be a
person whose entire identity is
predicated on that you know things I
don't know how people do that it's like
I don't want to be a guy that people
everyone's arguing with you yeah
the president of the Ukraine wasn't he a
stand-up comic right yeah
he's just practicing his English I'm
just like here's something that I can
say
well that's relevant with all those
media guys like I always think of like
they must have hard days too and to them
they have to like schedule like okay I
gotta say something [__] up about
trans people on Tuesday and then we
gotta find a Oklahoma and then we had a
whole [__] thing about black people
that I gotta run over it's like their
work you know remember black crime yeah
crime yeah they put it in their personal
agendas Tuesday 7 P.M black crime
isn't that weird though because it is
like they have to be that on top of like
their uh wrong ideas yeah yeah yeah you
gotta like rehearse their like wrong
ideas like we rehearse our jokes yeah
yeah like in the car like the Jews are
taking our money is
so which word invokes the most hate yeah
yeah
is uh deplorable better than uh [__]
I don't know did you guys see the
Holocaust Museum Twitter that Elon Musk
took their check mark away and they were
tweeting at Elon like really [__]
upset for this check mark that cost
eight dollars and I was just like if
you're running the official Holocaust
Museum Twitter account maybe just pay
the eight bucks and avoid
this uh playing into this like oh you
know those Jews
yeah
well that's funny like the tattoo is
sort of like the original verification I
was thinking something along those lines
but I didn't know how to word it yeah
well you're welcome thank you yeah there
are a whole lot about just saying it I
don't know you're thinking the whole
check mark thing is is strange
I think nothing and I'm sorry if anyone
has done it but
on Instagram sometimes you'll see people
like
two three thousand followers with like a
blue check and they're supposed to get
like you know 80 likes I'm like who are
you fooling who are you trying to fool
yeah I feel like you lost credibility
right yeah you can just buy it or
whatever yeah it's like the point of a
check mark is to uh say that I'm a
famous person and now no famous people
have it and you can just buy it so the
whole point of it is ridiculous it's
like here here's like an eight dollar
thing that I bought and then you just
come off as a try hard wanna be famous
person yeah it's like buying your own
trophy or something it's weird so it's
weird it's weird as [__] I like it
because when I see people that have done
it and they're like [__] then it's
like that's what that's funny that's
what this it's like it's like
verification with such a like heavy
thing for people like oh I'm verified or
whatever and now like all the stupidest
people have it because the only people
that are getting it are people that want
to pay eight bucks to trick people into
thinking they're famous yeah but it's so
funny because it has like the opposite
effect from me like whenever I see
someone with a blue check who like
doesn't have that following I'm just
like what a [__] loser
we want to trick us all on the thing oh
and even people I've liked it I saw Sean
Riley did it
I haven't told them him this to his face
yet but yeah
yeah
you shouldn't do that I I'd like it for
some people because it's like they're
playing a joke on the whole thing I like
that is fun the irony is fun yeah if
you're a nobody and you have it I bet
Sean is doing it that way I'll give him
a benefit yeah but I wonder if they do
like uh you know like a reel or
something or an ad on Instagram if
people are more likely to like click on
it because they see the thing there they
don't know you know immediately how much
followers you have or whatever
I don't know that might be a possibility
probably I always feel Bamboozled when I
click on someone with a check mark and
then like
I don't know some of the Instagram ads
are it's there's no barrier to entry
some of these bands and music that I see
on Instagram I'm just like what the [__]
is this it's like three 14 year olds
and uh keep clicking on the profile so I
keep getting them just like all the
Austin like shittiest bands ever and
it's really funny like the way that
people like do makeup to make their own
Instagram video at home for like their
400 followers and their band or
something it's like do people still
listen to music I hope not
yeah music is just podcasts from morons
yeah
oh you can't handle listening to a
four-hour conversation
you need someone to sing it to you
oh you need something that's three
minutes I only use music as a means to
meet and have sex with women that's what
I use it for yeah I say oh I love Death
Cab for Cutie you know that is one of
the most common things in the uh that
you can bring up in conversation
everyone will talk about
so if you're ever trying to get laid
fellas that's pretty good I gotta
remember that
hey hey Miss
you ever heard of music
Melody what melodies
what Melody speaks to you yeah what's
your favorite guitar chord
I just I'm just yeah whenever someone
asks me my favorite music I just started
listing like popular bands that I like
not my favorite
I just wanna it's like let's just have a
conversation about musicians Ed Sheeran
what do you think about Ed Sheeran but
nobody wants to be seen liking Ed
Sheeran no even though he's very
talented yeah
it'd be funny to like be a chair and
you're like um my dreams came true
and then you become so famous that
everyone
secretly has has to has to pretend that
they don't like you yeah yeah do you
think Ed Sheeran is like Kevin Hart in
comedy
um yeah yeah I think it's similar
it wants to get so like you know for a
general audience that like nobody
specifically likes you that much but I
mean he does have a big fan base it's
just like it's just cool to hate him
because it's like it shows that you're
not like everyone else
but that's because he is popular enough
where you could theoretically think he
is
for everyone else
I used to empathize with like rich
people and like famous people getting
like hate or whatever and now that I've
been uh at bottom of the barrel no one
gives a [__] with me and I have no money
for long enough I'm just like you know
what I don't care anymore you have a
house you have a career it's like get
over it who cares you know what I mean
wait because people are like rich people
can be sad too for a long time my 20s I
was like totally totally and now now I'm
30. I'm like you know what I don't give
a [__] anymore like stop being sad yeah
the uh empathy I'm losing empathy for
like I have no AC we're about to hit a
Texas summer here uh oh yeah it's
[__] summer coming up again soon
empathy goes out the window
it
that's [__]
I don't know
celebrities during covet like taking
videos themselves inside their houses
and trying to be like sad or whatever it
was just like
what are we talking about let's say
each of us get
100 million dollars today
what do you think everyone else is doing
like what do you think that you guys are
doing yeah yeah
Hans you're definitely buying probably a
mech suit I would imagine
something Tech based yeah
I feel like you would get one of those
uh
like a hoverboard
yeah like or one of those things in the
ocean or these Japanese people get like
a Sharper Image yeah everything from
Sharper Image yeah cons buys sharper
you'd buy like a Formula One car and
then it would just like sit in your
driveway all the time you'd never drive
it we just have a cool Formula One car
you would get like
something that it feels good like
flashlights and I imagine a lot of lube
you think voice towel because I'm not a
millionaire is the reason I don't have a
flashlight you think that's the barrier
is that me having a blush I just feel
like you want need a lot of comfort and
feeling homey and safe and cozy
it's all about a snuggie yeah yeah that
leaves a lot of money left over there
what if you bought something that people
loves a lot and then you make it into
like a comedy club or something
like Joe Rogan yeah or like not even
like a good comedy club but like I don't
know you know like something that people
like going to
I don't know what can I think of
obviously laser tag no like like uh I
don't know you know if you could buy the
capital which is impossible but
something of that caliber I'm gonna buy
the capital building and turn it to a
comedy club that'd be sick I'm gonna buy
Riverside Drive and I'm gonna set like
mines that I can definitely at any time
I want
like unlimited income like that it would
be fun to just get Billboards all around
the country and just put whatever you
want on them within like the confines of
legality like just fake advertisements
and I love [__] like that yeah that's so
fun oh I would pull so many [__]
pranks
I would I would
just destroy people's lives yeah at
least they're psychological you will
like uh you know Bucky's on this exit
and there's nothing there you know [__]
like that yeah [__] yeah
it's just a ramp too
like a roller coaster tycoon
yeah oh that'd be so funny you guys ever
see Rat Race yeah yes
there's like this scene where
these two old women and cars are like
selling
nuts from their squirrels
and they decide the people traveling in
the car stop and they're like buy these
nuts and like not get the [__] out of
here and so they don't know like which
way do we go to get back and they're
like
yeah
and then yeah it's like a pit
and they get like murdered or almost
murdered I remember there's a nice naked
breast scene in that movie even though I
think it was PG-13 but I remember being
in the theater and you saw a side Booth
this girl had like a piercing connected
to her nipple and a flash
with the tongue piercings yeah yeah one
of my first titties that I ever saw as a
child and I said I like that I'm a fan
of that you know what I think they
should do you know like uh the electric
electric chair or whatever like people
that uh how do you say that
um you know they're gonna kill the
government is gonna kill death row yeah
um they should do like an event where
they throw it like in the zoo in like a
bunch of hungry tigers or something and
then people uh buy tickets and then
those tickets go to the you know to the
city or whatever but at least you know
you're having fun and then you see that
guy trying to like survive and he gets
eaten yeah that'd be cool oh Gladiator
Warfare would be really great if he had
that sort of money you just build houses
with traps and uh unsolvable puzzles
like timers and snap their jaw or
whatever
or create create your own like squid
games like real life yeah yeah exactly
like you get a bunch but maybe a
different like you know not killing
people but like paintball yeah yeah yeah
for sure you know be a good theme for an
escape room is like a terrible comedy
club and then on stage the whole time
while you're trying to figure out how to
get out it's just hacky comedy camera
it's got like just ruining or not yeah
and you're just like panicking just
trying to get out as soon as the host
gets on stage a glue fills the bottom
live yeah to do a [__] 72 hour show
yeah you get a bigger and bigger
backpack as The Show Goes On you have to
always get narrower
and the comics get worse that's just
cold chicken tenders that's it yeah wow
if I had money
so uh what do you think about the whole
um
Sudan crisis there's a crisis in Japan
yeah what happened everyone out what's
he being sued for
um what what's going on in the news
wasn't there something big happening in
the news
recently beats the [__] out of me oh uh
the singer of The 1975 apologized to I
spice for the comments that he made last
week yeah that was the story
I've been following that one pretty
close
yeah something big happening at sedan
yeah some some like uh like a natural
disaster or like a war or ah Rebels and
the Army are fighting wait a minute
there's people fighting in Sudan
what oh my God
I don't know I don't know what's
happening I'm sorry I don't know
anything about anything is that in
Africa
really all right okay I know what's
going on
um yeah I mean I think uh there's a lot
happening in the world right now I like
when I bring up like a subject and then
like someone's like I haven't heard of
that like I don't know anything about it
and it's like oh what else do you not
know about let's talk about everything
you don't let's talk about I got a lot
of things yeah dude hit me okay so the
sedan thing is Rebels are fighting
against the government and there's like
unrest yeah you didn't know about giant
C squid so I gave her that one didn't
know about Giants what else is happening
why are they fighting against the
government
I don't know okay
I don't like the way they're running
things I thought you were telling me to
ask the questions that we didn't know
and you would answer them for the girls
but no I'm saying like there's people
I'm like let's pitch
Francisco asked the questions he didn't
know or Francis asked the question well
I don't know most things just walking
into a place and you just asking
questions yeah yeah
is that the are the train still
exploding are there child soldiers
because those are I mean it's horrific
but it is fun to think about
you know it's like different sized
soldiers like there's a big one with a
small one it's like kind of changed out
the battlefield a lot you know what I
mean how are we gonna get through this
Jungle Gym yeah I don't know it just
seems interesting because like when you
play a video game there's different
types of animus right in Halo they got
the little guys look at the big guys so
when you fight in Africa that's like the
same thing you got a squadron a little
dudes running at you and one big asses
would it be to get killed by a a kid and
there's you know how they are on they
would laugh at you know how they are in
Counter-Strike or like
Modern Warfare whatever they're like
laughing at you as you die like haha I
owned n-word yeah
what if the whole Army is just midgets
and you think it's kids
I don't know midgets would be the best
what you ideally would have is like
wasps with
AK-47s yeah just going I think alongside
a [__] in a Mexican you got something
you know the smallest possible thing
holding a gun he's basically a gun just
have guns yeah loading guns yeah and you
can just do a simulation be like who
would win okay
that that would that would be a better
way to do it war is just uh who can buy
the most
guns yeah and then you do like a virtual
battle
yeah and then that decides the fate of
the other why don't you just flip a coin
I think yeah Power slab would be a good
way to decide just get your biggest guy
RVs together to kind of slap each other
in the face until one of them Falls over
we're looking for someone who's been
practicing on their wife for years yeah
the best slapper I just feel like power
stops 10 000 hours well you don't think
once everyone has just robots that it's
gonna be like playing a video game
because everybody's just gonna be in
some room just controlling the robots
and hopefully if we have robots we can
learn how to get along
yeah what do you think AI is gonna you
think we're gonna
that's gonna slip out of control
I hope so you hope so yeah I mean it
doesn't seem like we're really
representing anything besides like greed
and like evil so like what is the point
of our civilization if we're just gonna
be like sentient evil greedy selfish
beings why are you saying that hands
I feel like that's what our society is
like right now I just don't like it I
don't like the way it is and I'm not
gonna like be like oh it's better just
to feel good do you think uh there's a
do you think there's a possibility of
changing things yeah yeah yeah I think
so I think it's really unpleasant I
think it's like unstable the way we have
it now like nobody
would feel good about this if they're
being honest you're giving me a real
John Connor Bob's right now huh are you
are you like rich people are too rich or
what's the
yeah
yeah they have too much and they're like
in the 70s they were like we're just
gonna make this whole society about
making ourselves happier
and we're just going to use people as
cattle to get rich
so how do you uh topple that down
um solidarity
Collective action
you know using our numbers to fight
their wealth you're signing like a North
Korean right now
or North Korea would benefit from
toppling are you more into uh like
communism or Socialism or what's your
ideal structure I feel like those are
just like uh
so
uh unpleasant words that people like say
it wasn't about say it wasn't
bastardized like I would just say like
have as few people at McDonald's in the
executive class and more
people as workers and just pay the
workers instead of the executives
because like that's just wasteful that's
not efficient do you think that workers
are going to enjoy their job more at
McDonald's if they make more money yeah
you think so yeah okay like in Denmark
they'll be like I'll make these Burgers
like I mean it
and then they'll be able to put up with
[__] more if you're getting paid
yeah but again robots you're probably
not gonna need workers as much anymore
oh that's gonna be so weird when like
most of the manual labor jobs are gone
and with that chat gbt [__] it's like is
our job gonna be gone it's gonna get
good work and write better jokes than us
yeah and people are just almost
downloading jokes yeah but like give me
all the ideas this is oh eating a
[__] watermelon is like having sex
with an Asian man so then it's basically
less about jokes and more about being a
great
performer and popular and physical and
physical yeah everything the robots
can't do yet yeah I feel like with uh AI
you're gonna be like okay I want to
laugh non-stop for 20 minutes and it's
just gonna create something and you're
just gonna laugh uncontrollably for 20
minutes wow that could be it really like
they just need to do so well and they're
like oh Francisco would laugh at this
for 20 minutes and then you'd pull off
your headphones or whatever and you're
like okay I'm good I can I can live
another day in this hellscape yeah
because it'd be like oh I know you
expect me to be funny right now so I'm
not gonna do it but whoa watch out a
lady bending over to pick something up
gets pantsed and then some monkey sticks
their finger in her vagina that's what I
think yeah you'd laugh at yeah
absolutely I mean that does sound pretty
funny
that sounds horrible I wrote a one-liner
today
but I wanna know are you testing out
bits that's what Paul's job is no robots
that ran out right better jokes than me
dude I'm like John Henry I want Julian
to read it and then trash it if it's bad
I'll beat the machine
all right
how come my dog doesn't understand my
Spanish but when I open the jar of
peanut butter she knows it's time to eat
my [__] okay I like that one I like
that one a lot that's good
thumbs up can I uh can I give you a bit
to read Francisco yeah oh my God this is
about it
you guys have your bits
on paper that's I like how you do it on
the notebooks or no cards that's kind of
funny this is Christmas morning well I
wrote a 2A and I was like okay there's
something here maybe I don't know I
heard it yesterday
wait I'll set it yesterday for the first
time on stage
and then I wrote it on a flash card and
so you wrote it physically today yeah
because it came up with it yesterday
because it's a one-liner so it's like oh
you know I might not use it but it's I
thought it was funny do you bring the
cards out there Francisco
um sometimes it depends if it's
something like this do you bring your
where you just came on like I came on
the station with you ah okay yeah
so uh how about this joke
it's amazing that people talk when the
alternative is not talking which is
amazing
I like it
yeah probably needs a couple lines after
but I like the premise a lot and like
when you're in an elevator and you're
just enjoying the sound of the machine
and someone's like so where are you from
it's like I don't want to hear your
disgusting organic body pushing air
through your soft esophagus yeah
are you AI
let's give it AI
he doesn't need things like breathing
anymore breathing is distracting
I'm nervous I don't want to do one let's
get a bomb I would feel bad about myself
it's okay
okay uh check this out
Francisco
this is a lot of build up to this how
long ago did you write this bit how far
on your phone I wrote this four years
ago Bill Clinton is such an [__] okay
I'm just really I'm tapped I'm just
gonna have to
I'm just gonna have you read this top
portion
okay
I have a special ability a superpower
really
where I can tell you if any soup tastes
good
Sue Professor Xavier seriously you give
me any soup and using only taste buds
on opinion [__] bro I suck
no keep going keep going okay
super Professor Xavier seriously you
give me any soup and using only taste
buds and opinions alone I'm able to
decipher which soup tastes good I made I
made chicken noodle and spoiler alert it
tastes good it's a gift it's a great
power but an even greater responsibility
deal in the White House is on fire how's
this cream of chicken soup it's pretty
good I don't know yeah oh [__] yeah
nice I feel like you were testing my
ability to read in English
I felt really [__] up
do you so like next time because uh
you don't you don't speak
Spanish dude yeah I do okay yeah it
would be so sad if English was my
favorite language it would sound like
this
have you been [__] people like that
when I was a kid like there'd be people
that couldn't speak English or Korean
well yeah like damn you just well when I
moved broken brain yeah when I moved
through my Hut used to tell me you're
forgetting Spanish and you're not
learning any English
which feels like what's going on
my dad told me that I'm under no
circumstances learning any Spanish as
well so yeah for a different reasons
learning is communist
but uh yeah I mean uh
I uh I I take like uh you know you're in
America and you're just like speaking
English a lot
you're not speaking Spanish and I think
like some people like they have it in
their mind like oh it's talking is when
I do this and they never change it so
like like when I talk I talk like this
and this is the Rhythm and I'm never
gonna change it and I'm just gonna
substitute in English words to this
the Rhythm that I have so it's like I
feel like people that are good at
languages are like they're like kind of
insulting the language that they speak
because they're like oh you see soy from
uh espanol oh yeah you gotta like
pretend to like be like a like a Mexican
yeah yeah you gotta that's what I always
thought about learning Japanese
yeah because if you don't speak like
that that's also like not good you know
like in order to like give the Japanese
respect you really have to use Japanese
with it yeah it's like what is offensive
am I doing just a caricature of their
yeah I think they sound like maybe if
you did like anime girl it would be
better
I think because the common notion is
like if you speak uh unbroken right
you're gonna sound like the people that
actually speak their language so that's
why like I have a lot of friends I they
learn English and they were always
trying to talk like you know hello my
name is Francisco I don't know yeah but
uh like crying like extra yeah so I
don't know yeah sometimes it's insulting
when people learn Asian languages and
they're like I'm like oh this is what
you think about Asians it's like
like girls that are like I love Asia
because I'm like a cute little
act like a baby with a cat filter yeah
yeah it's like our culture it's like you
get you can laugh in your native tongue
you don't have to laugh like
yeah fine
[Laughter]
okay out of uh us four Huns rate us all
most racist to at least racist oh no uh
Francisco number one racist you are
definitely number one hence well I mean
am I included in this yeah yeah you're
included how am I racist well the same
the same way you're rating me being
racist because I feel like you're rating
me based off my stand up I feel like
you're just honest about race you're
just like oh Mexicans are oily you know
that's not what I said you guys ever
noticed that school buses are yellow I
love Mexicans school buses are yellow
and also the people who usually do
really good at school are
because
all the [__]
so you got Francisco and number one who
was racist
then who's two three four and yourself
included oh
I've transcended race
personally
some people are better
hiding the fact
of not being racist yeah they just don't
think about it like white people are
good at just having blank spots where
they're just like oh not gonna talk
about it yeah I'm really good yeah I'm
so good at that yeah
that might be the best of that let's
let's do this who do you think whose
parents you think are there more most
racist oh that's a good question
because that's how you were raised yeah
your parents I feel like would be a lot
racist my parents yeah why because they
have to be they have to be raised
realists to survive and also when
they're coming from you know a country
that isn't in the first world then it's
like you are more brutal and you take
more joy out of
the more Primal racism
okay I I think
as maybe I'm putting the Hans as number
one racist
third world dirty country you wouldn't
know any better okay love the simplest
stupid games of racism I wish I could
stay and talk about how I feel about all
the races yeah unfortunately after yeah
no Paul's the most racist because he
refuses to engage in the comments yeah
Paulie's like I I didn't know Latinos or
black people existed until I moved to
Austin one year ago I only deal with the
corporeal form now I don't really deal
with that you're not racist if you never
have to see or deal with other races
that is true
of all of us
Paul takes the lead yeah
kill streak
where are you going I
am okay like I physically work or stand
there yeah
all right now's your chance to sneak
into the Vulcan Paul's working the door
hell yeah come by shoot me in the head
what's going on at the Vulcan
oh uh there's a show tonight I'm doing
it's the one where you do seven minutes
sober and then seven minutes High
is that drunk versus no different show
oh yeah I guess this is just a weed
smoking show I love that drunk versus
high though I always get drunk and I
always [__] kill hell yeah when I'm
drunk and then when I'm sober I suck oh
yeah yeah
I think that's generally do you really
see like a difference in like you ever
you you always go drunk on stage or no
no I just I think I'm uh funnier
and a better person when I'm drunk when
you're lose more loose yeah yeah you're
not so thinking about yourself right
yeah or like what people think of it
yeah when I got a few in me I'm like who
[__] cares yeah yeah why can't you do
that when you're sober I wish yeah it's
hard it's hard because you're more in
your head and you you're more aware of
your feelings and all of that alcohol
can you just force yourself not to yeah
you can I mean but it's not as easy as
it sounds
because uh also it happens to me like if
I'm if if I have a few drinks I feel
like a little bit more loose you know if
I'm super sober I'm more thinking like
oh [__] my set and like ah there's
pressure oh I need to kill or whatever
but uh and then and then I end up yeah I
mean I feel like if you're gonna torture
your body and drink you might as well
try to force yourself to act drunk but I
think also like uh When You're Sober
it's like [__] like I could force myself
to think this different way but then
what's the point and then I get all
eor-ish
so I feel like if you could just find a
way to just be like hey [__] uh the
Eeyore part like yeah just uh act drunk
right now
and maybe like that's kind of annoying
like someone who isn't drunk but is
acting drunk and then you can get do
more shitty things yeah because you're
not drunk well if he comes more like
putting an act like you know I'm just
gonna pretend like I'm lose
like you're an insecure person at a
party just passing out to get attention
right I got uh I got drunk the other
weekend and uh punch punch Francisco
yeah very hard I didn't think it was
that I thought you were like Angry for
like for real so you kind of like hurt
my feelings for for a second
but then I saw you go outside and punch
uh Ray extremely hard as well
and I'm like okay I'm not killing you
one he's just drunk
that's what I do if I like you and I'm
[__] faced I'll like hurt you and he
will say he was like I like you man and
he kept saying that and he kept like
punching me
I thought he was like being sarcastic
and he was saying like I hate you like I
did something that I'm not aware of yeah
now I'm like what did I do like it was
really I was excited to see him yeah
South by Southwest and you were very
drunk yeah but I didn't know you were
very drunk until like after I I started
like observing you because I felt like a
little like hurt or whatever like my
feelings more than anything and then I'm
like oh yeah he's just [__] faced so I
feel better about that and for us very
selfish reason I felt good when you
punched right
is that how you think like a guy that
gets murdered by a serial killer would
feel be like oh thank God it's not just
me he's doing it to other people yeah
yeah yeah I think he was like just kind
of like softly punching you but he
wasn't realizing how much force he was
putting into his heavy hands I'm like
Lenny dude I'm like we're the rabbits I
saw my friend
yeah yeah you could like get you could
get Dylan to assassinate people just by
being like hey you see that guy that
guy's your friend go say hi to him yeah
give him a hug
oh [__] how what's what's I mean I've
seen you draw group a couple times we've
all seen each other drunk a couple times
what's the main Vibe of everybody
Hans you like
you keep pretty cool you say some wild
[__] uh
should we get [__] up tonight yeah
probably should just do a part two to
this podcast I think there's a very fine
line because once you get too drunk then
you're going on stage is a [__] mess
yeah you know you don't it's like yeah
pretty fun if it's like oh this guy's
having a good time but then it's like oh
this guy's incompetent and he can't yeah
and you're not respecting whatever
you're doing or the audience or anything
because you're just like yeah you know
[__] you here whatever I have a big dick
and then you go to your jokes out of
weakness yeah out of panic you guys
didn't laugh or oh
it sucks I'm like the funniest one I'm
not doing my material yeah and then and
then I go back into it it's like [__] I
hate this [__] yeah I used to love your
sets at uh boss meal like on Friday you
were like drunk and you were just like
you could tell you were just like having
fun that was a blast oh yeah did you
ever go to that you just [__] Crush
it was a great
I'm so pissed that that's gone now yeah
it was like the Friday why they didn't
want it I feel like the bar didn't want
it they all the people who worked there
did because they got more tips and more
business but yeah I think regulars
I don't know who it was but there was a
noise complaint that's what it boiled
down to on Riverside relax yeah exactly
and it was from someone playing their
guitar it wasn't even one of the comics
uh so the snow performances yeah no
Friday or Saturday Mike only Tuesday
I I guess that's such I'm sure they have
other shows and stuff but yeah that's
bad but yeah it's crazy like you can
tell how long Mike is Gonna Last by the
way the bar treats you
yeah yeah and similarly how Comics treat
the bar yeah yeah you guys remember uh
[__]
Roma room oh yeah and then that guy
just said [__] everyone online on a
weird note yeah he was like he was
pretty light through all everything it's
like you're winning the race and then on
the on the last [__] you know
straight you just decide to go like this
to the audience yeah yeah you're like
killing and then you're like n-word [__]
you but yeah exactly
like I saw that post I was like oh I
liked you I thought you liked us yeah
that's crazy it's like that that uh you
know the in the bicycle race where the
guy first Falls and then everybody
everyone behind fall you know follows
yeah that's exactly
he just lifted for no reason he just
went scared he's like [__] you guys
ungrateful [__] or whatever yeah yeah it
was literally it was that one I still
want to think that he has had a moment
because he was a very nice guy he was
nice
it's hard to run a club when you're not
there yeah yeah
I guess and like they got mad at people
for not staying for the open mic
yeah it's like that's an open mic yeah
yeah also like running a mic is brutal
for everyone yeah you shouldn't try to
monetize mics
no not uh here although I do like the
system
of everyone
I so in La they have this place called
the fourth wall and it was five dollars
for five minutes but it only lasted the
mic was 50 minutes total so it's like
you know 50 to minutes to an hour
and then you would stay for the whole
mic is this in Los Angeles and there's
like an intent during the pandemic no
well yeah they had a tent one too they
had a bunch of them but even before the
pandemic they were going and I agree
with not doing the five dollar thing but
it was nice being like okay I can
be at a mic from four to five and that's
exactly how long I'll be there and I'll
get up you know yeah and especially like
if you have money and you have a job and
you're like I have money when I don't
have his time and patience to deal with
but if you're a comedian you probably
don't have money because like if you
want to be doing it yeah like you won't
you kind of have to be broke in the
beginning unless you're you know getting
money from other ways yeah so like
nepotism people have an advantage and
then like people that are unemployed and
good at being yeah Beggars yeah but you
don't think the you know like the
patients that you build or whatever is
kind of like a discipline that you have
to it's kind of like a skill that you
have to
um I guess uh you you get from from that
from the mics from going from driving to
shitty places I'm waiting for three
hours I'm performing in front of you
know four people and so that's
definitely one way you can develop but I
don't think that's the only way and if
that helps you you should use that to
help you but I don't think if you're
creating a comedian in an ideal
environment I don't think like putting
more suffering in is good I think it's
just like that's what we have to deal
with and we just get used to it and you
use it yeah ourselves but I also think
like when you you know something doesn't
go as planned or whatever show you're
like man I've done shittier [__] before
you know it's kind of like a way of
thinking about it like in a positive way
I guess that's true sometimes I have
nights where
like it'll just line up and I bomb like
the first two or three shows or like you
know
uh in my head a bomb and then by that
like third or fourth show I'm just like
I don't give a [__] about anything and
it's hilarious yeah you know because
the the access to that pain I would
always like before an important show or
audition as I would go to like a couple
hell mics before and just get all the
bomb out
and then when you go up
it feels like such a breeze in
comparison yeah yeah that is interesting
because
you know bombing at mics before can if
you don't have if you haven't been doing
standard for a long time you can really
you know like remove your confidence and
be like [__] I don't think I'm you know
funny anymore why am I doing the show
but then once you get the first laugh
you're like okay
you know you're like okay yeah yeah like
doing a mic no like saying like you do
two shitty mics or two shitty shows
before that got real like important show
yeah if you you know you bumped or
whatever there's not like an audience
that if you don't if your confidence is
not
um you know shut up how can I say that
like you can take your confidence away
yeah and you're like not delivering your
jokes as well and yeah like you know
they used to do like this one minute mic
before kill Tony yeah and I did it like
two eyes and I would always bomb because
it's only comics and if it's in the
middle of a bar that's all yeah and it's
like bro like now I'm signing off for
kilton I have no no confidence in that
minute this is a mic where we destroy
the show kill Tony by ruining people's
confidence and everyone that goes up is
sad
yeah so I think it's a bad idea to do
the minute Mike is this still going on
well
there's two takes yeah it is they do it
at Sunset now but there's two takes it's
a bad idea if
you're trying to get confidence on that
one minute but it's a good idea about
what Dylan saying like just kind of like
warming up and you know whatever and
getting the bomb out of the way so I
don't know
yeah I mean if you understand how to
take it in if you do the set and you're
like oh this is what it's going to be
and this is how I should take it then
it's yeah then it's good
um my uh
girlfriend has been helping me a lot
with like
[__] whenever I'm about to go up at a
shitty mic she's like are you gonna get
mad at them
are you gonna be in a good mood
I was like oh [__] I had to think about
that that's good to hear yeah that is
good to hear because sometimes it's like
just that that makes some like you pull
out of it I I notoriously do that yeah
because it's a [__] show the whole
point of it is to like [__] uh
perform and have a good time so if
you're not wanting to be there and they
like resent you for it like it's like
what's the point the whole like we could
not do this then yeah so like if it's a
show then let's operate under the
assumption that you want to be here and
I want to be here yes which is I think a
better way to do it and I think it's
easy to lose that in mics where it's
like nobody really wants to be here
yeah but again I think it gives you it
helps you build that muscle in like how
do I get their attention and keep keep
them engaged yeah what do they want to
hear because the attention span is just
so so short so if you're like well in
front of like a real audience they're
like okay I see where you're going oh
take me on a journey with you but at an
open mic they're like get to it [__]
give me what I need yeah yeah give me my
[__] juice yeah I feel like you're
like what's what do they want to hear I
feel that's why all this the first jokes
or whatever are like such like you know
one-liner type deal like setup punch
yeah you got to get them quick with that
first laugh and that first laugh is like
how they're going to respond to your
Rhythm yeah that's how uh
peebly would describe building his like
late night sets is starting
with shorter jokes at the beginning and
then eventually his bits get longer in
the set but then uh Steve Martin talks
about trying to get people to laugh even
before you say anything and I think
there's a lot of Truth in that or like
how you were saying Francisco like
setting the tone or like gets you on the
Rhythm them on the Rhythm beforehand
that that first few like that first 10
seconds is so important yeah I think
Jordan is very good at that Jordan yeah
yeah he's very good at like when he goes
on stage
um getting the audience to get into his
rhythm before even him opening his mouth
and they're already like you know
engage and you know giggling they're
they're they're ready and it's like
everybody just came to him instead of
him coming to the audience yeah he's
like the first laugh is very important
like that's where they establish
that I'm funny and then you can go from
there
I also do like the comedians though that
started off really like poorly and dig
themselves out of something yeah that's
really cool too yeah
like that short guy that's been on kill
Tony a couple times he does that
I was like oh you guys all look like
you're here to catch a train huh and
then he like turns it into something
funny oh that's cool yeah because he's
like he's not like saying that to
denigrate the audience or to like you
know use that to boost himself be like
oh so I'm gonna bomb it's okay he's just
saying that like as a noticing thing and
then he's like you're gonna use that to
like Riff on it and like he's a good
riffer that's cool who's that guy I
don't know
I'm kill Tony white guy bearded
but yeah I think uh
it's uh good to do different kind of
shows but
I think it's good to do good shows more
than bad shows yeah
because yes more like real comedy and
you can actually go with ideas and you
have control like bad shows are good if
you don't know what you're doing and you
can just like bounce off of them and
figure out what they want but if you
have like a goal and a plan you can take
them to like heights and you can like
expand upon what you're already saying
so I think it shows there's a higher
ceiling yeah that's what I like about a
little boy so much is I feel like it's
like a perfect mix of the two it's a
good show like it's always like sold out
and stuff but then at the same time that
room does require like work
so it's like it's kind of working both
of those muscles at the same time yeah
the audience has a lot of power there
yeah they can unionize and be like we're
all not laughing at that together
I was a hosting this week and I was
there was a couple times where they were
like oh [__] you know but I love
I love the short jokes in between
yeah and and also that's a good exercise
and you know because that show can be
three hours sometimes four hours yeah of
like how do you
get keep someone liking you
and I'm seeing you like 10 seconds at a
time over four hours
10 20 seconds yeah they're like what are
you doing up here do you need to be up
here right you're just wasting our time
making us like you what a waste of likes
someone else yeah that's so stupid it's
like you're at the [__] show relax
yeah this is the [__] show you signed
up for right you're getting what you
paid for [__] we're not doing this for
no reason yeah have you ever been to a
comedy show before this is how all of
them work you [__]
yeah when you have to do round robin
it's such a pain in the ass because you
got to be like who's up next yeah and
then if you have a host you're like oh
he can just change the show at a
moment's notice yeah and yeah you don't
know and then it's always like some guy
from [__]
[__] Ohio that is important somehow
and you can't [__] it up yeah oh your
name's Mike kramster noon yeah like be
sure to remember that as I'm focusing on
my own [__] yeah really you should just
be able to say give it up for your next
comedian yeah yeah and then they come in
Dave Chappelle comes on yeah it's like
who gives a [__] what his name is before
you and then like the credits thing I
think the credits thing only gets the
stupidest audience members to be like oh
he's been on Comedy Central let's pay
attention now
those [__] long ones I got one I'll
do some moon tower stuff they would hand
you these index cards of the person's
introduction so that you could memorize
it before you know and this one lady it
was literally like three sentences it
was like this next comic you've seen on
the Ohio
and she's also got a show at eight at
800 Congress this coming Saturday at 7
30. you've seen her on The Tonight Show
The Late Late Show with James Corden The
Tonight Show with Jimmy and then it's
like yo I'm just gonna say Comedy
Central
it's comedy and it's centrally located
and people will recognize that
and they say oh well that's a thing yeah
who's gonna remember oh she has a show
Let's uh remember the date and time and
why do I have to say The Late Late Show
with James Corden yeah say the late show
or even The Late Late Show I'll give you
as if anyone gives a [__] you know well
I feel like it could be good if it was
like an official thing like if it was
like a commencement and yes yeah if we
were at the Mark Twain Awards then that
introduction would make sense but at a
comedy show you could be like next up is
this [__] yeah well she's literally
running a six minute set I think that
you know I think one credit is helpful
in a long show where people are like oh
you know it's time to leave and then
they hear comedy Center okay let me just
stay one more and watch right whatever
it is that's the wrong energy I know
yeah I know but you know sometimes you
need some [__] to keep the audience
there for the next comic yeah it does
help if you're like oh this guy's been
on Comedy Central let me pay attention
yeah well like let me know go to the
bathroom for this guy yeah and then the
next guy is like Netflix okay let me
just stay for this one too I've been
doing this intro for John Heff that I
really like where I go up and I say
this and and I've been working on
different variations but I basically say
this next comic is a piece of [__]
uh he's been accused of many things none
of them good and uh
anyway yeah like Smeagol [__] loser
anyway give it up for all right hold
your applause
for someone better ladies and gentlemen
the squirrel rapists John haft
that was there it was funny I just bury
him and and [__] and I think it's it's
more fun to the audience
because they're like oh he's obviously
joking but he's got like a personal
relationship with this guy yeah and
that's like a it sets up a dynamic and
John Hess like
you know looks like Golden Child you
know [__] goofball so they never like
believe that what I'm saying is true you
know yeah
um yeah I was there and I remember
thinking the same thing like that's you
know the audience can tell that you guys
are probably very close off stage and it
was pretty cool in a way almost better
than saying Netflix
um yeah but then there's like a
expectation where like oh this guy is
gonna be a cool guy just he's gonna be
friends or like when you're introducing
your friend yeah yeah it's like it's not
going to be some professional business
set it's going to be like uh he's gonna
be in the moment and he's not gonna make
things too weird because he's present
yeah it's so much more fun yeah and you
were also you know giggly and people
knew you were joking it was great how do
you feel about like having like a
co-hosting at the same time because I've
seen you do that too I I have fun doing
it with uh Jeffrey burner because he's
like a weird [__] about it and I I like
that uh
it does make it a little different it's
just so much more
of a production and then people like oh
you're like forcing yourself to go up
there it's like it's a whole thing like
if it's just one person it's like oh
this is the smallest number of people
necessary yeah it is the the minimum
it's definitely a different challenge I
but I I [__] with hosting a lot I like
it
yeah I think it makes you a lot better
because it makes you like focus it makes
you be like
um part of the show yeah you gotta
listen to the other people set and like
there's things that you pick up on and
you know that like oh this person said
this thing and it bombed and they
haven't forgot that yet I'm gonna
re-bring that up
[Music]
well what I host I try not to bring up
anything negative I try to be like this
guy is amazing that guy I don't know
what if I make fun of them it's not
really about something negative but how
do you bring up a bomb like that because
well I've never I address it I go wow
and then they usually laugh really yeah
well well as perceptionally at the
comedy Mothership Open Mic because when
when it's like the people on the open
mic it's like you know there's so many
people that like right but then if you
start doing that you gotta do and
someone bombs even more and then someone
bombs even more you're just saying like
you're just talking about bombs the
whole night but that doesn't happen yeah
I think it's good because it reminds the
audience you know there's uh real Comics
or better comedy coming up in the near
future you know and that guy is a good
comic maybe just had a bad sense and by
him addressing it and the audience
laughing They're laughing so they are
kind of also you know getting a little
bit of their money but I also think it
sets the audience up to be like
uh oh let's see if this guy bombs or
kills it's very binary and I feel like
Jeffrey burner you know like he might
not get as big I'm not saying he does he
murders all the time but someone weird
like he might not get the big laughs but
it's still like artistically a beautiful
thing that happened so I feel like it
sets the audience up to be like kill
bomb well see that's the thing is I
don't when it's something artistic I
don't say that yeah one is just like
some guy who comes up and like there's
this guy on the mic I'll try that one he
said there's like he's just he went up
and immediately said like
[__] something but like without a joke
behind it and then so after I said all
right uh that was our last gay comedian
of the night and then they they all
laugh but like in those scenarios where
it's like 40 plus people I like well
Escape comedian isn't even an insult
that could be a positive thing
I guess tone has a lot to do with it as
long as you give them an out to be like
you can laugh at this without being too
negative I feel like it's good yeah yeah
like uh someone bombed yesterday and I
was like give it up for that person
she's a liberal
um I bet they got a big laugh yeah yeah
I hope so
I think it now I'm like it's not funny
I I was you know because at that open
mic at Mothership again there's like 40
people on the show and I at least
and there's one you know sometimes I
just don't think of something clever and
so one of them I just said this next
comic is a woman
yeah yeah
how'd you know about that I was there oh
yeah oh yeah and then they were like oh
I guess it's the woman
but that's the thing it's like that's
funny but like the audience doesn't
isn't able to make the correct uh
response to that because they're like
okay we're getting ready to clap oh wait
he said something funny okay so we'll
clap that oh so then well that's the
thing that I find the challenge is like
it feels repetitive saying ladies and
gentlemen give it up for yeah ladies and
gentlemen it's a rhythm account for that
hat yeah it's like [__] I gotta figure
out other things to say
then like ladies and gentlemen give it
up for yeah but they need to give it up
for
yeah or do you think they know like 10
comics in that that's the Rhythm that's
the routine yeah I never thought about
it but I guess that is the phrase give
it up for because it's like we've been
on Netflix comedy central give it up for
John yeah what else could you say Comedy
Central on Netflix it's John heft
yeah you can say that that's what I'm
saying
yeah welcome to the stage yeah
but I think it's just better to say the
name because I don't like being like
come on guys clap everybody come on I
know unless you do it like and you own
it like Tony does where he goes on stage
and you know what he does I don't want
to ruin it but yeah he just like makes
people clap and it's funny because
that's like his personality too yeah
that is fun yeah yeah
comedy sucks
yeah it's hard
it's like why am I changing myself so
much for these people
[Laughter]
yo I uh
I feel I I've had some [__] terrible
bombs at Mothership but it's been uh
nice having that pressure back again
even though it sucks sometimes
it feels like the pressure of The Comedy
Store all over again in terms of like
performing and how did I do and like all
that sort of [__] yeah there's like a
pre like I feel like a new comic again
there you know it feels like
oh [__] like I'm not even close to how
funny I thought I was
how do you treat uh like newer bits at
the mothership do you bring them up
there or not really I haven't I haven't
found my confidence in there yet which
is a weird Catch-22 because like usually
those times where you
you know when you have like a new bit to
say and you're just like saying it
because it's fun and then it works
is like
I haven't found that Comfort yet at
comedy Mothership to to go up and do
those sets
because you want to do well but at the
same time sometimes they do well you
need to be more free so it's like this
weird uh cycle that I haven't quite
tapped into yet yeah
because I even see like you know uh you
know bigger Comics I see them going you
know a little boy
and they are still doing like their you
know [__] that works at the beginning
and at the end and they're kind of like
sneaking in their new stuff in the
middle
um so we like compared to like uh you
know whatever Open Mic it's like oh yeah
I'm just gonna do all of this new [__]
because I'm excited about it you're not
like but over there it feels like you
want to like play it a little bit more
safe you know like because there's that
pressure there so what do you think huh
um
well I don't really do other sets a lot
I mean I I only do new stuff that I know
pretty well yeah and some of the new
stuff is more reliable than the old
stuff because like I tell them better
you're more excited yeah and I'm more
present for us and that sets the tone
for the rest of the set so sometimes
it's like the best move to do do you
taste test them at your own shows uh
yeah sometimes
do you put them in the middle or do you
do them up top or I do it up top yeah oh
that's cool I like that yeah if it's an
up top kind of thing like something
about Austin or something about the
weather local thing I feel like or uh
something in the news works good up top
yeah so they're like oh this is all
going to be just uh about you know like
if you they say something about
something that happened recently then
they're like oh this whole set is about
just came up with recently
that's a good point yeah yeah it does
bring it like a this guy is current and
this is like who he is because he's
talking about now yeah yeah yeah yeah it
puts you more in the Forefront and the
in the present so
I think it's good sometimes it's good to
do a bit that you know works in the
beginning just so you get them on board
but I don't know I feel like even if you
bomb with a new joke they can see that
you're being authentic
and hopefully if it's a good audience
they'll give you some slack
uh but yeah it sucks if you bomb with
the new joke up top and you're like you
have to salvage the rest of the set dude
my first
my first two sets at Mothership were
bombs and little boy I'm like amazing
lineups and I went after all these
killers and I just saw said killers in
the back of the room like three minutes
and stand up and walk out and I was like
oh no it devastated yeah
that's the worst when someone walks out
on you oh yeah it's like you can all you
can also see that door open when you're
on stage yeah
in the little boy room you see
you see the door of sadness yeah a ream
of light and you're like no
the light of bombing yeah yeah it's a
different sort of light you know I
always notice that door like on on
either because they have either side
doors on the back and then you just see
the door open and after like a bad joke
and you're like [__]
yeah the whole point of this uh when
you're doing comedy in that room all
you're trying to do is keep that door
still yeah everyone
the tricky part is out there sometimes
people walking from one door to another
yeah but you get uh almost like are they
is there someone that he's walking
through or was it a person already there
was it a waiter yeah
where the [__] is going on yeah you
gotta chalk it up to away but that's how
you know also that you're bombing
because you're paying attention to that
door yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah because if you're in the flow
and you're killing you're not you're
just like you know you're present with
whatever the [__] you're saying yeah
whatever you're killing it feels like
kind of like a dream where you like oh
have I been up stage on stage that long
you know kind of like a state of like
hypnosis it feels like it goes by very
quickly yeah when I'm doing well yeah
and then when it's going bad I'm like
yeah the door yeah the way that customer
clinked his glass
door is like you're having a dream about
someone giving you a [__] and then
you wake up right you're like [__] yeah
yeah just like that
and then the other is haunting yeah I
always I would think of like the little
boy room is so fascinating to me because
like
um I guess like the challenge of it have
you guys ever seen Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire it feels like the scene
where like all these friends go into the
Maze and there's like trumpets in the
background like yeah we're doing it and
then we all walk in and then the walls
change and we're all alone it's like
laughs
when you step on stage sometimes
you know
some demented person in the court
trying to kill you or whatever it's like
it is so funny and then you just like
hear the trumpets fade away in the
background that's such a funny scene
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
man last time I performed I had a little
boy I realized that this stage is way
bigger than what I thought initially I
thought it was this size
and then last time I realized it was
like the size of this table
yeah it's huge
yeah but the entire time I thought it
was this small yeah what like a dice I
guess we well the reason why it is I
think it's because of those the two
walls that lead up to it so it it like
just makes it look narrow like it's
pinching yeah but I'm also saying like
forward like forward you have like more
space there than what I thought I guess
because the first times I performed
there I was like so like so much like
pressure like my vision was just like
yeah
I'm only thinking about side to side
yeah but yeah behind you Casey's new bit
is great because it's like he's using
oh yeah behind the stage as well and
then popping up and then popping out
hilarious yeah I like how he uh uses
space yeah and he also had things
explores the physical space yeah that's
cool
um yeah I think uh the uh the little boy
and the the comedy in general when you
step up it's like you're like preparing
you're like oh [__] oh [__] oh [__] and
then when you go it's like ah
yeah yeah totally
do you uh what do you think about the
big room Hans and which or which do you
prefer to perform it
um the big room just because of the
prestige and the status yeah Power aside
what yeah uh
um like I feel like the big room can be
like
the the audience is like wide-eyed and
in shocked they're like wow where are we
oh no and the little room they're like
comfortable it feels like the audience
has more power there and they have more
like they're they're more like ahaha
that was funny and the big one was like
was that funny like they think about it
a little bit more they got more time
yeah on it yeah it's more like a [__]
you know theater experience it's not
really like a club
experience like the little boy is yeah
yeah I know I I've done a set in the in
fat man and even noticing like the role
of laughter going back
is is uh
it's strange like timing wise we're just
listening to it I feel like real comedy
fans go to the little boy I feel like if
you're not a real comedy fan you go to
the fat man because that's all you you
know is like just flashing lights and
like Showmanship and all that awesome
[__] no but at the same time people are
good or fat man for the most part
they're there to see someone
specifically right yeah they're a big
fan yeah I'm not I'm not saying it's
like always true yeah I think the I
think in general both rooms are amazed
yeah yeah what is like little boy you
could [__] you can hear like a chair
move
you know so it's like so it's more
intimate and if someone says something
you can hear it
do you guys ever listen back to your
sets and you hear someone say something
terrible about you in the audience
you guys ever get that yeah yeah I
haven't done that yet because usually I
bring it with me like my cell phone with
me in my pocket oh so you don't yeah I
mean like you don't hear like a video
recording yeah video recording and
having uh got in that yet but I I do
capture like the different laughs it's
like why this [__] didn't laugh at
this one and then he left at this one
because you know they're closer to a
camera so it's like Mitch hedberg's joke
yeah I love people with distinctive
laughs because then I can tell which
jokes you don't think are funny oh I
just stick to that doesn't think that
joke was funny
that's really true I've memorized like
people's laughs over the years have you
ever been in a scene with someone with a
distinctive laugh and they would use it
like a cudgel yes like stupidly just
wielding it yeah and like they can't
even stop themselves they're just too
far down that road they can't just
change their laughs now
terrible it's just stupid stupid uh
strategy I think we should we should uh
change our lives every like two to three
years I remember in the in the OR
I would
when I was doing like a set there I
would put
uh my phone down by the booze
and where the comics were sitting and
then I'd come back and some people
wouldn't have realized that I was
recording myself
they're like no he's not funny
that's such a good place to put why
would you put it there it's not the only
place you can put it because I need to
know who my enemies
you're putting bugs you should just
install bugs yeah no it was literally
just you know like I just put it on the
table and then I go up and do my set you
know because I didn't want to have to
like worry about anything and then sure
enough he's here like
and then obviously there yeah that guy
owes me 20 bucks yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly but sometimes I hear audience
members too like say [__] that they
think I can't hear yeah and it's like
yeah I'm gonna listen to this 40 times
so it's not just you heck like once it's
the 40 other times I I you listen to
yourself I saw you listen to your set on
the couch you were like passing out or
something we're just hanging out playing
a tan we were done and you're just like
listen to your set I was like damn
that's like how you need a because
either you don't listen to your sets at
all or you listen to it like a freak I
listen to it like a freak I'm literally
just like 4 30. I started doing that
yeah especially if I have a set that I'm
like thinking about a lot it's better to
listen to it than to just obsessively
think about it yes yeah I think so too
and I think it like
that's
so crazy that you listen to yourself
that much oh hours like they'll just be
in my bed
and just and then sometimes I'll run
into that same way it can't be fun you
got to be doing it because you hate
yourself to some degree maybe it's a
little bit of both but then but then I
offset it by I have sets that I go to
for joy to lift me back up again really
bad time like sometimes from years ago
I'll like listen to this I was like oh
remember that time September 18 2008
that's a perfect yeah just your your
biggest fan where I had that moment yeah
exact set to make yourself feel the same
the way you want exactly but I feel like
listening to your set is also a good way
of you know removing
fat or whatever adding new tags and [__]
like that yeah um or why did I say this
like this wait did I use this word or
whatever
because then you're like oh this is what
the audience is feeling what I'm feeling
right now because I'm just listening
right that is the weird thing too is and
sometimes you have like misconceptions
about the audience
and like or I I do that a lot too where
I'll think they're like against me but
they're like just clearly not back here
but then I'm combative and then it's
like well now you got an Applause right
yeah you get an Applause break and
you're like oh you didn't like that oh
am I too edgy for you like they just oh
I guess I think I should call my parents
more huh
[__] that's not even relevant to it oh I
guess I littered yesterday and you you
just can't forgive me oh you guys all
saw me later were you all there
[__] knew it man yeah you think you
that much better than me son of a [__]
yeah yeah I I [__] so sometimes I'll
hear [__] mean [__] like just
sometimes it's literally just like it's
this lady gonna like I don't like this
guy and then I hear it like 45 times on
a night oh my God you gotta stop leaving
it
I feel I identify with the lady right
now yeah this ladies making this lady's
killing it well that's why I listen to
her I feel like that is I feel like that
is helpful though because like me I I
already have those thoughts in my head
like those dark thoughts about like oh
nobody likes me and I suck I know well I
was at a show and I heard a lady in the
bathroom be like I like the other guy
and it's not like she said she hated me
or she thought that I think I was better
but just the way she said it I was like
oh I know what you're trying to say why
were you in the woman's bathroom it was
like that hallway leading into the
bathroom and I was a headliner so if you
say the other guy I was the last one
it's like oh not that guy but that and
the way she said it was like oh you just
don't like me I'm glad that that is the
one of the things we all share is there
will always no matter what these shows
where people don't like us for whatever
reason yeah that's okay even if you kill
yeah even if you kill especially if you
kill they're like oh that guy killed I
like the other guy now yeah yeah
I've been trying to get better at that
because usually I will go to the mics
um you know care a lot about like other
Comics what they think about me and that
could like impact my set or whatever I
wanted to do that night if like someone
walks in at the time and they were like
booking a cool show I feel like oh I
have to like impress them in a way and
at the end of the day you know if they
like you they like you if they don't you
know a lot of people are not gonna like
you so but I I mean like just catching
the audience you know saying [__] and
then I feel like that has to be good
sometimes they are not even saying stuff
that they feel they're just saying [__]
just because they think no one's
listening they're like ah [__] this guy
or maybe they don't think their their
friend likes them so they're saying
that's who you like by their friends
yeah yeah that's the thing it's like and
then it's just you know the [__] up
part is is yeah if you buy into the
noise then you can kind of morph their
words because sometimes I'm hearing
those recordings and it's like muffled
so it's like you know I'll hear like you
know a joke doesn't work and I'll hear
like
she say
he's fat and he should die yeah
like just the tone of voice and the
Rhythm yeah yeah I can fill in what oh
yeah I think they might have said or
when you hear something and you deep
down you know it's true you know yeah oh
I can't understand a word he's saying
and I'm like [__] I need to articulate
more I need to slow down I need to use
uh easier words you know it's so funny
how audiences don't know how like
psychologically devastating they can be
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah why wouldn't he just do stand up in
Spanish
have you gotten that one before I mean
I've gotten from Comics [__] around
but you know it's kind of like true in a
way
and it's like I just need to do whatever
I can so like by just like slowing down
knowing my my material you know
um it's weird because if if I'm like dry
mouth I get in my head I'm like [__] I'm
gonna [__] this word blah blah and
sometimes I take like a bigger pause
just to like be okay I'm gonna be able
to pronounce this word and then for some
reason you know the audience thinks
you're making like an artistic pause but
he's just me in my head like I got this
word
I got this sentence
but uh yeah
all right uh I gotta go you guys want to
keep going or no no I'm good okay hey we
should play guitar again though yeah
this is the perfect table for it it's
great
all right all right later Hans all right
that was good right yeah yeah I feel
like I got going you got fun
um